♪♪
Narrator:
It started with a simple idea ‐‐
match the country's
most innovative,
passionate entrepreneurs
with the most prominent,
accomplished business investors.
They'd be using their own money
and investing
in real businesses.
We got a deal!
Narrator: With over $100 million
invested in the Tank so far
and monumental successes...
I want y'all to think,
who's next?
Narrator: ...it created
a new genre of TV...
[ Cuban laughs ]
Even you couldn't have predicted
this kind of breakout success.
You're not only making
profits,
but you're creating jobs
all across America.
Narrator:
...and proved that business
could be entertainment...
[ Cheering ]
...and that entertainment
could be educational.
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
Narrator:
And this season...
Leave me alone.
No! Bro!
You're not involved
in this.
...some of the most influential
and successful titans
of business join the Tank.
Frankel: I haven't been in bed
with so many billionaires
in at least a couple of weeks.
Narrator:
Sara Blakely, creator of Spanx,
grew a single idea
into a global fashion empire
and is the youngest American
female billionaire ever.
Sold!
We got a deal!
Alex Rodriguez,
iconic baseball legend,
has built a business empire
over the last 20 years
and has reinvented himself
as a formidable entrepreneur
and investor.
I always invest in the jockey
and not the horse.
I think you were
a winning jockey
from the minute you walked
through that door.
Narrator: Rohan Oza,
venture capitalist
and the marketing genius behind
some of the most successful
food and beverage brands
in the world.
And I take these brands
to the promised land.
Narrator: Bethenny Frankel,
creator of the Skinnygirl brand,
parlayed her television fame
into a global
lifestyle juggernaut.
No disrespect to everybody here,
you can't find a better partner.
Narrator:
And tonight, Richard Branson,
billionaire founder
of the Virgin Group,
is recognized
as one of the most innovative
and successful entrepreneurs
of all time.
People thought we were mad
doing Virgin Galactic.
People will think
you're mad doing this.
Whoo‐hoo!
Narrator: A groundbreaking
new season begins.
♪♪
We'll do that deal.
We'll take that deal.
No, we'll do the deal.
We'll take that.
We'll take that! Hold on!
Cuban: Sacrifice is part
of being an entrepreneur.
Don't feel sorry for yourself.
Go get the job done.
‐[ Sobbing ]
‐We're not doing this.
This is motivation.
We're gonna dig down.
The dream is free and the hustle
is sold separately.
A lot of people saying to me,
like,
"Oh, you're not gonna make it."
Herjavec: What's the best
revenge in life?
To get even.
Narrator:
And it all begins...
Whoo!
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...now!
[ People gasp ]
♪♪
And that is how you do a deal.
[ Beep ]
Mark, let's see
who gets on that platform
and skates down.
Cuban: It won't be me.
Won't be me.
Richard?
Oh, this has got Richard's
name all over it!
I've broken enough legs.
[ Laughs ]
What extreme sport
do you like the most?
Well,
it's not really extreme.
I just love kitesurfing.
‐Awesome!
‐'Cause I live on an island,
I can do it every day.
It's just great.
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a young entrepreneur
who solved the problem
he had with his favorite hobby.
‐All right.
‐Better catch that wave.
Cuban:
Whoo!
[ Branson laughs ]
Easily.
John: Hey!
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Carson Kropfl.
I'm an 11‐year‐old inventor,
skater, and surfer.
This is my friend Sierra.
Hi, Sharks!
Hi, Sierra.
I'm his mom, Carrie,
and we're from
San Clemente, California.
I am seeking $60,000
for 15% of my company.
You just saw
my first invention.
It's called Streetubez.
It lets riders surf anywhere,
any time,
because it looks and feels like
you're totally getting tubed.
My second invention was when
I first started middle school,
and it was the first time
I ever had a locker.
My locker was decked out
and awesome,
but none of my skateboards
would fit in it,
so I decided, "What the heck?
Why not just make
one of my own?"
This is a Locker Board.
Locker Boards are handmade
and reshaped from recycled
skateboard decks.
At only 16 inches long,
they fit easily inside
of backpacks and lockers.
And they're good
for the planet.
Thanks, Mom.
Let's pass out some samples.
Robert, get on the board.
[ Laughing ]
I'm gonna get on the board.
Thank you.
Great.
Wow, Carson.
Love the hair.
‐Thanks.
‐Thank you.
Very cool.
Thank you, Sharks.
Bye.
Bye!
Good job, Sierra.
Bye, SiSi.
Great job.
Oh, that's cool.
[ Sharks chuckle ]
Sharks, the benefit of you
investing in my company
is that you'll be a part
of something
that has been inspiring
people all over the world.
I've been surfing with sharks
since I was 5 years old,
so go ahead,
hit me with some questions.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: All right.
Normally, a skateboard's
this big, is it?
Or...
Uh, yes.
Is this the first time anyone's
ever cut it down to size?
It's the only skateboard
that fits inside a backpack.
But I've seen
small ones before.
What's unique about it?
Uh, they're good
for the planet,
easy to take anywhere,
and they're super fun to ride.
And also, the square shape
lets you still do tricks
'cause of the corners,
and your feet can stay on it
and it won't be too wobbly.
Where are you getting
the old boards from?
Vans skateboards has a monthly
recycling program for me
at two
of their skate parks,
and I get about 50 boards
a month from them.
And they give them to you, or,
right now, you're buying them?
Give them to me.
Are you selling any today?
For nine months,
I've been selling
all over the country.
How are you selling it
across the country?
Online?
Social media.
Really?
He's made $10,000 in revenue
since he started.
So, is Sierra your girlfriend?
[ Laughs ]
No.
[ Laughter ]
What kind of look
was that?
Herjavec: Wow!
What will you do with the money
if somebody puts it up?
Manufacturing,
upgrading my website,
buying trucks and wheels,
hardware, in bulk.
How many skateboards
have you sold?
I have sold 231.
What does it cost you
to make one?
So, the deck costs me $3,
but now Vans put me in touch
with their manufacturer,
Madrid Skateboards,
so that costs $13,
and I'm now selling them
for $52.
Wholesale.
Wow.
‐Wholesale.
‐Retail, what's the price?
$99.
Where do you make it now?
My husband set up a shop
for him,
and he's been making them
in the backyard.
Branson: I remember
when I started in business,
my headmaster called me
into the study and said,
"Look, you either leave school
and you run your business
or you stay at school and
you don't run your business."
I was 15.
I said, "Okay, I'm off."
I dropped out of high school
when I was 16,
so I waited an extra year.
Did you really drop
out of school at 16?
Yeah, in high ‐‐ Yeah,
I was a high‐school dropout.
‐Did you go to college?
‐Yeah.
I was 16,
dropped out of high school,
started taking
graduate‐level classes,
and got my MBA
by the time I was 19,
transferred those
back to high school
so I could graduate
from high school.
I'm curious, Richard,
what was your first business?
My first, sort of,
was to start a magazine
to campaign against
the Vietnamese War
that was going on.
So, it became a national
magazine for young people...
Wow.
...and that was
my education, but...
Look, this is great.
But you're gonna stay at school,
so you're gonna have to learn
to delegate...
Yeah.
...because too many people think
they can do it all themselves.
So, Carson, you said
that you had gotten
some help to make these 'cause
you can't make them anymore.
What's your deal with them?
Madrid Skateboards,
and they are manufacturing
my boards, doing everything,
and then I just put
the trucks and wheels on.
How do I know there isn't
a Carson in New Jersey
doing the same thing?
The main reason skaters buy
product is for brand loyalty.
So, when they go to buy
a Locker Board,
they're gonna want
not some fake.
Two ‐‐ they're really hard
to make.
You have to have
all the right equipment,
all the right hardware.
And three ‐‐ I'm
in patent‐pending status.
You kill it, Carson!
Bam!
‐Drop the mic!
‐Buh‐bam!
‐Bam!
[ Laughter ]
Listen, you're amazing.
But I'm not going to invest
in the company.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Carson, where do you want
to be a year from now,
two years from now,
five years from now?
I want to be...
everywhere.
[ Light laughter ]
That's a lot of places.
He sound‐‐ He sounds
like one of us.
What's been amazing,
online's great
because he has
much higher profit margins,
but he'd also like
to be in retailers
because it does give him
a lot of credibility.
Right now, he's in
a Southern California retailer,
Jack's Surfboards.
He's in two of their stores.
You know, here's what I think.
You know, I would not invest
in your company now
because I think that you have
so much growth,
and giving up 15% or 20%
of your company right now
is absolutely absurd.
You have a lot of room to grow,
and I think you'll do it
without us.
So, I'm out.
Okay.
Cuban: Carson,
I love what you're doing.
I want to make you an offer.
Okay?
I'll give you the $60,000,
but I want 20%.
And my plan is not just to help
you manufacture
'cause you have Madrid
to do that.
That part's all taken care of.
Yes.
...but to really help you
build up your YouTube,
help you build up
your Instagram.
So, if you want
to be my partner,
I'm happy to make
the investment.
Wow.
What do you say?
Branson:
Before he answers...
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I‐I was gonna suggest that ‐‐
You keep on touching me.
I was gonna suggest that ‐‐
You keep on touching ‐‐
I was gonna suggest that
you and I work together on it.
Nope.
No?
No. All right.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So, what do you say
you and I work together?
♪♪
Oh, I know.
If he's not gonna work with me,
I'll make you an offer.
I'll offer you $65,000
for 20%.
For 20%?
So Carson, I'm...
Robert?
[ Chuckles ]
I love things
that are cool and fun.
I really don't think
you should sell
any of your business
at this point
because it's just too soon.
I don't want any of the equity.
What I'll do is I'll give you
the $60,000 as a loan.
What interest‐rate, Robert?
Whatever bank rate is,
like, right?
Okay, 8%, give or take.
Right?
I'm offering $60,000 for 20%.
Wow.
And Sir Richard Branson
is offering $65,000 for 20%.
‐And we're gonna help ‐‐
‐What would you like to do?
♪♪
Richard,
if you're gonna invest,
how would you help
my company?
Oh, you're gonna
interview him?
Wow!
[ Laughter ]
I like that!
I like it!
You got guts!
Wow!
Well, you said you wanted
to do everything.
I remember,
I had this magazine,
and somebody wanted to buy it.
Went to lunch
to sell the company.
So I said, "I'm gonna start
Student Airlines,
I'm gonna start, you know,
Student record shops,
Student this," and they
got completely panicked,
and so when you said
you wanted to do everything,
I remembered that moment
when I wanted to do everything.
Let me be honest.
I see a young Richard Branson
in you.
You've got a wonderful story
to tell.
You're very articulate.
The product itself is great.
We'd love you
to give it a shot with us.
[ Chuckles nervously ]
♪♪
It's a deal.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
All right,
let's have a hug.
‐Yeah!
‐Great.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Great. Great. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Great job, Carson.
‐Great deal.
Good job, Carson!
Good job, Carrie.
‐Good job.
‐Thank you.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you so much.
[ Hushed voice ] Yes!
[ Hushed voice ] Wow!
You know,
wanting to do everything,
that really hits home, I think,
with all of us.
It's contradictory to, of
course, what everyone's taught.
I mean, I think about when we
started the show nine years ago.
That's the biggest change.
As I go around
the country...
Yeah.
Cuban: All about the kids.
...half the people that
come up to me are kids.
It's all about the kids,
yeah.
Yeah.
I chose Richard Branson
because he would help me
the most.
Internationally, right?
Internationally.
Yeah.
And also,
he had the highest offer,
and I felt like, "Phew!"
Make a little bit more.
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is what
the entrepreneur believes
is the next big
recreational revolution.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Aaron Wypyszynski,
and I'm the founder
of Wyp Aviation.
I'm from Huntsville, Alabama,
and I'm here today
seeking $500,000
for a 20% stake in my company.
♪♪
Throughout history,
humans have dreamt of ways
to take flight ‐‐
the airplane, hang gliders,
wingsuits.
Once in a generation
comes a new advancement
that helps us further
this dream.
Now is the time
for the next leap.
Introducing...
a wakeboard for the sky.
‐Oh!
‐Now, don't try this at home,
but let's take a look at it
in action.
The WingBoard combines
the thrill of skydiving
with the control and command
of wakeboarding.
W‐‐ [ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
Once secured to the board,
the rider simply leans
and manipulates
intuitive controls
to carve through the sky.
Man, that is cool.
What?!
Holy...
Now you can feel
the exhilaration
and freedom of flight
like never before.
Oh, my God.
Through indoor
flight facilities,
we're bringing the thrill
of WingBoarding down to Earth,
providing a unique human
flight experience
in a safe,
controlled environment
at retail locations
around the world.
At Wyp Aviation,
we're opening aerial sports
to an untapped market.
Through our patented technology,
we're bringing all new meaning
to the term "surf the cloud."
Now, who's onboard?
‐Wow.
‐All right.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I have a question.
‐That is cool.
Greiner:
Is this to be done outside,
or is this, like, you know,
where you go parachuting
in a retail environment?
It's both.
So, the extreme‐sports
professionals
that we've been working with
are chomping at the bit
to do this behind an aircraft,
but right now,
we're actually holding off
on doing the flights outdoors
because we want to make sure
our facilities ‐‐
You don't want to kill
anybody.
We want to hold off to do that
because every time we go out
and do a flight event
with the board,
we get a huge
media‐attention blast.
So we want to wait for that
until we've got
our indoor flight facilities.
Who did the video?
That was actually our 40% scale
model that we've got
that's a fully articulated
robotic rider.
So, we used that
to prove out the flight.
Oh, it wasn't a person.
It was a robot?
That one was a robot, but we've
actually got some video
of one of the GoPro skydivers
in a wind tunnel
flying this exact board
indoors.
Well, let's see it!
[ Wind blowing ]
Goblin!
[ Laughs ]
That is so cool.
Are those ready yet?
So, right now, we've partnered
with that
wind‐tunnel facility ‐‐
it's actually
outside of Toronto ‐‐
and we're working with them
to do our customer events.
But that didn't look fun.
So, the fun part comes in.
In there, you can actually
start to maneuver around,
and you actually wear
a VR headset.
But you're not moving, right?
You're just balancing.
So, you're actually flying
on the air stream.
How ‐‐ How did you actually come
up with this particular idea?
So, the idea came from
a childhood cartoon
called "TaleSpin."
And one of the characters
in there
would jump out of an airplane,
throw a board under his feet,
and grab onto a rope
and get towed behind
the airplane through the sky.
About four years ago,
I was thinking,
"You know, that always
looked like so much fun.
With all these
extreme‐sports guys out there,
why hasn't someone
done this yet?
Like, it seems like
kind of the next evolution."
But just to be clear,
you haven't actually
ever done this live
behind a real airplane?
‐Not behind the airplane yet.
‐Only with the robot.
With the robot, we have,
and we've done
the wind‐tunnel testing,
which it exactly mimics.
Richard,
you're a daredevil, right?
Like, you like to do extreme
sports and things like that.
Well, yeah, I suppose.
I ‐‐ Do you mind
if I have a try?
‐Yeah.
‐Yes! Definitely! Hop on!
All right,
let's get down to this.
That's how it ‐‐
Yep. Put a foot up here.
Okay.
That works.
Oh, with that.
There you go.
Slide your foot
under the back there.
‐Oh, my God, that is so cool.
‐Wow.
Wypyszynski:
There you go.
You can put
your index fingers on here.
‐Ooh!
‐That's cool.
And that's what allows you
to do the barrel rolls...
Herjavec: That is cool!
...when you're on tow.
Yeah, 'cause you want to do
barrel rolls behind a plane.
[ Laughter ]
Will you take off attached
to the plane, yes?
You do, yes.
You take off
like a glider.
Right.
So, I'm actually
a glider tow pilot.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
How did that feel
to stand up there?
It's ‐‐ It ‐‐ It ‐‐
It's gonna be a real thrill.
That's for sure.
The thought of that, physically,
to me, is just not appealing.
I don't know that I would want
to go have that experience.
I'm out.
It's really cool
when I thought it could kill me.
When I saw it in a wind tunnel,
it didn't look as cool.
Yes.
So, the wind tunnel ‐‐
So, what's the business?
The idea is the wind tunnel ‐‐
And that wind tunnel's
a little bit restrictive.
So that's the only
business today.
You're not trying
to get us to invest
in something behind
an airplane.
You use the airplane
to drive the marketing.
You pair with someone
like a Red Bull
or with Virgin to do
a big marketing campaign.
And how much is it per hour?
I guess you're gonna
be charging people?
Right, so it's actually ‐‐
It's very comparable
to indoor skydiving.
Indoor skydiving
is anywhere between
$70 and $80 for a two‐minute,
first‐time flight.
And we're right in that region.
So we're about $80, $85.
So, what's it cost to build
one location?
So, one location is between
$4 million and $5 million.
Oh!
Herjavec: What?
‐So...
‐Whoa. Wait a minute, here.
Yes, so that's very ‐‐
It's actually a little bit
less expensive than building
an indoor skydiving facility.
Aaron, how much money do you
think you're gonna have to raise
before you can get
your first location open?
So, we're looking for about
$2 million to $3 million
to open that first location.
And then we're ‐‐
You said it was $5 million
to $6 million just to open.
And then we're gonna ‐‐
We're gonna finance the ‐‐
the rest of that.
So you got to raise $3 million
and borrow $3 million.
Correct.
Yes.
I think it's gonna
be expensive, obviously.
I think it's gonna be tough
to borrow the money.
And most importantly,
I'm terrified of heights.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I've done indoor skydiving,
and I thought I was gonna puke
before I hit the ground.
And so it's just not
a fit for me.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
I know that I was on your mind
as the number‐one Shark
in aviation to invest in.
[ Chuckles ]
You are the action‐sports guy
on this panel.
I am.
I just think if it's going
to be successful,
it's gonna take a long time
and a lot of money,
so I'm out.
You're lucky
Richard's here today.
Branson: Well, as ‐‐ as you
know, I love adventure.
People thought we were mad
doing Virgin Galactic.
People will think
you're mad doing this.
This is intriguing to me,
but investing $500,000 with
what you've presented me today,
I just can't get to that.
Good luck, but I'm out.
I'm like Richard.
I ‐‐ If it goes fast
and it's slightly dangerous,
I just want to try it.
I mean, I've parachuted.
I'd go into outer space
if Richard sold me a ticket.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐He'll sell you a ticket.
If you ever have a service where
I can get behind an airplane,
I would definitely love
to try it.
[ Chuckles ]
But as a business
where you've got to raise
$5 million to $6 million
per location,
ooh, I don't ‐‐
I don't know about that.
I would love
to be the second one to try it
right behind Richard.
[ Laughter ]
But for now, I'm out.
‐Thanks.
‐Congratulations, Aaron.
‐Thank you very much.
Cuban: It's really cool.
It was a pleasure
to talk with all of you.
Congrats.
♪♪
Some people think
that the WingBoard's crazy,
but, you know,
every new aviation invention
people think's crazy at first.
They thought
the Wright Brothers were crazy.
We just are taking that
to the next level,
and it just takes time to prove
to people that this is it,
and we're going for it.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an innovation
in the camping space.
♪♪
[ Rooster crows ]
‐Oh.
‐Aw.
‐Tricked us.
‐Ha ha.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, man!
[ Laughter ]
Wow. That was a good night
of sleep.
Baby.
I feel rested.
Ahh.
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Richard Rhett.
And I'm Juli Rhett.
And we'd like to introduce you
to our company ‐‐
Sierra Madre Research.
We're here to offer
15% of our company
in exchange for $175,000.
At some point in life,
most of us have
the fantastic idea
to embark
on a camping trip.
We head out
with a grand sense of adventure
only to end up
tossing and turning
on the hard, uneven ground,
and then waking up
cold and wet
from a storm
that soaked the tent.
Well, Sharks, we're here
to elevate
your camping experience.
Sierra Madre Research...
[ Laughter ]
...is a solution‐driven
outdoor gear company
that designs and creates
the most innovative,
protective,
and comfortable
hammock camping equipment
on the market today.
We have pioneered
the ground‐to‐air tent segment
of the outdoor market.
So, Sharks, which of you
would like to join
Sierra Madre Research
in elevating
the camping experience
around the world?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Great job, guys.
But wait.
Before we get started,
I know somebody needs
to come up here and take a nap.
John: Yes!
So let's get in.
Come check it out.
Yeah, yeah.
Come on, Richard.
Come on. Guys, you can put
two people in each tent.
I'll look at it.
[ Grunts ]
There you go.
Now...
[ Screams ]
[ Greiner laughs ]
And then put your legs
over here on this side.
Juli: There you go.
Oh, this is fun!
Come on, Lori!
How did you get in?
[ Laughs ]
Look at them!
Oh, my God!
Could the neighbors
keep quiet, please?
I'm trying to sleep.
Is it gonna crash?
[ Laughter ]
‐How does it feel?
‐Oh, wow!
‐Yeah!
‐This is so cool.
You can toss your cellphone
in this pocket.
It's very strong.
That was really fun.
Yeah.
That thing was
really, really strong.
I'm glad you got in.
All three of us
hopped in that thing.
Richard:
So, it's super‐strong.
That was so comfortable.
I love the mosquito netting.
I love
that you're off the ground.
But how do you get that
up into the tree?
Yeah.
How hard is that process?
Sure.
So, this goes around the tree.
All you have to do
is reach up to your height,
what's comfortable for you.
We've got three main parts ‐‐
the rain protection,
the insect protection,
and the gear stash
where you put your pack.
It all clips together
with color‐coded clips
so you can easily see where
your attachments needs to go.
What does it cost?
$350 for the entire
package here.
That's including a hammock,
including the suspension system,
including two carabiners.
What would that cost you
to make?
Well, we have a 62% margin
on that.
Are you the only hammock tent?
We are not necessarily ‐‐
We are the first,
but we're not the only
hammock tent at this point.
'Cause there's others.
There are shelter systems
that are designed for hammocks.
Are there shelter systems
like yours?
No.
No, no.
We've created a technical tent
for the hammock community.
That hasn't been done.
Richard ‐‐ Richard, would you
put these on Necker Island?
[ Laughter ]
I would ‐‐ It seems great
if you're going
for individual camping,
but I mean, I think
one of the romantic things
about going tenting
is you have your partner
with you, and ‐‐
You think we haven't
tested it?
I mean, I'm knocked up
right now. It's ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
Oh, you are?!
Congratulations!
Wow!
Richard:
That's number three.
This happened in a hammock.
That's number three
right there.
It's a hammock baby.
Yeah.
All right, you guys got to stop
going camping.
[ Laughter ]
How did you come up
with this idea?
2009 ‐‐ On a medical
mission trip in Honduras,
providing clean drinking water
for people that don't have it.
80% of the people
that we ran across had illnesses
based solely
on clean drinking water.
Sleeping in a hammock,
I was up in the air.
It was lightweight.
But I wasn't comfortable.
I'm an engineer ‐‐
analytical mind.
Why do we have
these two problems?
When I go home,
I start sourcing fabric,
trying to find a way
to make a better hammock.
We come to find a‐a solution
in creating products
that add value
to people around the world.
We take a small portion
of our profits,
and we dedicate that
to drilling clean‐water wells
in Central America
right now,
which we would expand to other
countries as we get bigger.
And that's our passion.
That's our ‐‐
That's what we want to do.
But you got to pay the bills.
You got to make a profit.
What are your sales?
Last year,
we did $208,000.
This year we are on track
to hit $430,000 to $500,000.
‐Wow.
‐All right.
How do people
find out about you?
Majority of our sales
are coming from word of mouth
and because people ‐‐
They buy our gear.
They tell their friends,
they ‐‐ their friends come,
their aunts and uncles,
their grandparents ‐‐
everybody's buying gear
from us
because
they've seen this work.
I think this stuff
is incredible.
Thank you.
Thank you, Daymond.
You're absolutely amazing.
You are the brand,
but I don't even know
how I'd be able to help you.
I think there may be
some better people up here
that can work with you.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
There's other ones out there,
right?
What's really different
about you,
and how do you feel you can go
up against the competition?
So, the competitors
in the market,
they're not innovating.
They're sticking with the tarp
and the hammock
with the bug netting
over the hammock,
which is claustrophobic.
Yours is better, clearly.
But my concern is I don't know
this market well enough,
and it feels to me like
it might be a crowded space.
[ Sighs ]
I have to be out.
If you haven't been
knocked off yet, you will be.
And it's not really an industry
that I think
is gonna get huge enough
for me to get excited about it.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
Richard, Juli, I've always
wanted to have a business
where I can wear sandals
to work.
[ Chuckles ]
I mean, how great is that?
I think you're doing
something great,
but I was waiting for that hook
to get me there.
I'm sorry.
It's just not for me right now.
I'm out.
And then there was one.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Richard Branson
is Richard and Juli's
last chance for a deal
for their hammock tent company,
Sierra Madre.
I really like your product.
But for me,
believing in the entrepreneur
is the most important thing.
♪♪
I'll give you
what you asked for ‐‐
$175,000 for 15% ‐‐
and 100% of any profits I make
will go to charity.
♪♪
What do you guys think?
I mean...
do we have to think?
[ Laughs ]
Yes!
Cuban: All right.
Congratulations, Richard.
We would love to take that deal,
Richard Branson.
Right.
Well done.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Good luck.
‐Excited. Excited.
‐Pleasure.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Whoo!
That's what we wanted.
That's who we wanted!
Aah!
We're excited.
Let's kiss.
Ohh!
Getting this deal
with Richard Branson
is amazing for our company.
We're gonna be able to make gear
for the entire world.
Also, I mean,
the guy's got an island.
We're gonna put so many hammocks
on that island for him.
It's gonna be incredible.
♪♪
I was brought up
south of London, in England,
by two wonderful parents.
We lived in a tiny,
little cottage.
I spent the days climbing trees
and rescuing cats.
My dream as a kid was I wanted
to get out in the world
and change the world
for the better.
I'm dyslexic,
but when I'm interested
in something, I learn fast.
I was 15 years old,
and a young man
brought me a tape.
I loved it.
I couldn't find any
record companies to put it out,
so I decided to form
my own record company,
and the rest became history.
Virgin is a way‐of‐life brand.
We're involved in something
like 300 different sectors ‐‐
everything from health clubs
right on through
to putting you into space.
We jump in where we feel
other people
are not doing it very well,
and we try to do it better.
I love adventure.
I'm also just somebody that
can't say no to a challenge.
Being an entrepreneur
and being an adventurer,
there are a lot of similarities.
♪♪
You're trying to achieve things
that have never
been achieved before.
I've never been interested
in making lots of money.
I love creating things.
The byproduct
of creating successful things
is you can actually end up
becoming a billionaire.
Man:
Richard Branson's made a career
out of breaking tradition.
Branson:
And I'll use those resources
to do, I think,
really worthwhile things...
from climate change
to conflict‐resolution issues.
I think "Shark Tank" influences
a lot of people
to actually become
entrepreneurs.
♪♪
They ‐‐ They watch "Shark Tank,"
and they think, "Oh, I could
do something like that."
And I'm sure there are a lot
of the future Richard Bransons
who are watching
"Shark Tank" today
who will become
the Richard Bransons
of the future
because of watching
"Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an easier way
to get into the habit
of a popular practice.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Yunha,
and I'm from San Francisco.
My company is Simple Habit,
and we're seeking $600,000
in exchange
for 5% of the company.
Ugh.
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
‐Now...
‐The Valley takes over.
Now, before you get stressed out
by these numbers
[Laughing] I'd like to ‐‐
So stressed out.
I'd like to invite all of you
to close your eyes with me.
Let's just take
one deep breath together.
Hmm.
Breathing in deeply.
[ Sighs ]
$600,000...
‐[ Snoring ]
‐$12 million valuation...
‐5%...
‐[ Laughs ]
These people are horrible.
Just don't ‐‐ don't ‐‐
Don't do business with them.
They're just horrible people.
Whoop‐whoop‐whoop‐whoop.
Breathing out slowly.
Open your eyes now.
Oh, it's only $2 million.
Where's my wallet?
[ Laughter ]
Feel better?
You just meditated.
Simple Habit
is meditation made simple.
Our five‐minute meditation app
is designed
for your busy lifestyle.
It's so easy to use.
Let me show you.
First,
download and open the app.
Second, tell the app
what you're up to.
For example,
let's try "Before Work."
Today, I'm feeling
the Monday Blues.
Man: Welcome to Simple Habit's
session on the Monday Blues.
Let's try and shift
our mind‐set today
and take it
one moment at a time.
Yunha: Voilà.
There's a five‐minute
meditation for you.
We create
thousands of meditations
by top teachers
from around the world.
You'll find meditations
guided by mindfulness experts
to executive coaches
who normally charge thousands
of dollars for their teaching.
But with Simple Habit,
you can get them all
right at your fingertips.
So, Sharks, please join me today
in helping the world
reduce stress, improve focus,
and sleep better.
Greiner:
The voice that we heard ‐‐
Is that the actual voice
on the app?
Yunha:
We have many teachers.
It's one of the teachers
on our app.
Do you pay people
for their voice?
We give out 20%
of our net revenue
to our meditation teachers.
The business has been going
for how long now?
Less than a year.
In your first 12 months,
how it's gone?
In less than one year
since our launch,
we've had over half a million
users use this product.
Wow.
Yunha: We've grown
from zero to $750,000
in annual recurring revenue.
Wow.
What's your own
personal background?
My dad came to the States
from South Korea
to study engineering.
My mom worked at Dunkin' Donuts
to support him, and I was born.
And then they went back
to South Korea for a job.
When I was 14, I decided
to come to the States by myself
to study at a boarding school
in Portland, Oregon.
I went to Duke for my undergrad,
where I double‐majored
in economics and Chinese,
and my first job out of college
was in investment banking.
One day, I had a business idea
that I wanted to pursue,
so I quit that job,
and that's how I started
my previous start‐up.
What was it?
It was a software business
called Locket.
Because ‐‐
And what happened
to that company?
So, we sold that company
a few years ago.
After selling the company,
I went to Stanford
Business School,
and it was there I started
working on Simple Habit.
Hang on, you've got
to do more with your life.
[ Laughter ]
You're just ‐‐ You're not
packing enough in.
So, if you ‐‐ if you've got
$750,000 in the first year,
what do you think you could
get in the second year?
Sure. We've been growing
at 50% quarter over quarter.
So, last month,
we did $75,000 in sale.
And this month,
we are on track to do $90,000.
And what's the cost?
It's a free‐to‐download app.
But if you want unlimited access
to some of our premium content,
for example,
meditation before an interview,
meditation for engineers ‐‐
‐So ‐‐
‐What does that cost?
$11.99 a month
or $99.99 a year.
So, how many people are doing
the subscription service?
Over 5,000 subscribers
as of today.
Do you have
a main competitor?
Yeah, there are meditation apps
out there.
In fact, this was why
I started the business
because most of the apps out
there only have one teacher,
and it's all that
his or her voice.
And after a while,
you start to tune out.
So you're creating a collection,
a vast amount,
and that's
your differentiator.
Right.
We're a marketplace
for teachers and students.
Branson: Were you ‐‐
Were you profitable,
or were you losing money
in the first year?
We've been losing money even now
because profitability
is not our main component.
Right.
When would you expect
to be profitable?
Herjavec: Isn't that nice?
[ Greiner chuckles ]
So, we're expected to be doing
over $5 million next year.
How much money
did you raise?
We've raised about $2.8 million.
‐Ooh!
‐Oh, wow!
‐What?!
‐Wow!
‐$2.8 million?
Yeah, for what percentage?
The latest round was
at $12 million valuation cap.
We used convertible notes.
How much of the $2.8 million
is left?
We have most of it
in the bank today.
We have about ‐‐
over $2.3 million.
So then why are you here?
So what do you need
the $600,000 from us for?
I'm here because I think
that you guys
can add so much value to us.
So, wait, wait, Yunha, if you
think we can add so much value,
why are you valuing
our contributions
as the exact same as any other
investor in this note?
Because that note
was from many months before
when we had much less revenue.
We didn't even have half
of our team at that time.
So now the risk of the company's
much lower.
So what is it exactly do
you think we can contribute?
For example, I think Sir Richard
could help us a lot
because your brand embodies
this chillness and coolness,
and that is Simple Habit.
You said you have
over $2 million left,
and you're not
gonna run out of cash
and you're offering us 5%.
What would you like us
to do for that?
We're planning to scale
user acquisition.
We're also going to start
doing a lot of partnership
with celebrities and influencers
because you need ‐‐
Like who?
So, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait right there.
I'm ‐‐ I'm so out.
I'm so out, so out, so out.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Did you hear what you just said?
You want us to pay you
and not be compensated,
basically, for our brand.
Yunha: No, that's not
what I'm talking about.
She's gonna ‐‐ You're
gonna go out and pay
a bunch of other people...
‐Right.
...but you want us to pay you
the same thing
that they're gonna do.
Sorry. Sorry.
Can I clarify?
‐Okay.
We would love to partner
with other celebrities
and influencers.
Cuban: But from
an investment perspective,
you don't need the cash.
That's a nice problem.
She's gonna get exposure
from being on this program.
She can get ‐‐
She can get good partners.
But, yeah ‐‐
But that's what she is.
She's a gold digger.
Hmm?
No, she's not a gold digger.
Did you just call me
a gold digger?
[ Laughs ]
Yes.
John: A gold digger.
Listen. That's not ‐‐
You know what it is?
There's so many people
around the country
that stand on that carpet
and they busted their butt
and they've sold their house
and mortgaged everything
they've had
and their kids' college fund
to hopefully get
$200,000, $300,000
to run their business.
Every time somebody steps
on this carpet
who has a couple of million
dollars in the bank,
you take away
the opportunity
of somebody
who may have lost their home
or sold their kids'
college fund,
and you take
that opportunity away from them
when you could
go get money elsewhere.
Oh, that's so unfair.
Herjavec: Yeah.
It is not. It is not.
I mean, no.
No, because ‐‐
Right ‐‐ We can only see
so many people, Richard.
Because if ‐‐ if ‐‐ if ‐‐
Because if you make money
out of her,
you've got more money
to give to other people.
No, no, no,
but that's not the case.
This show is because
of the people
who had no place else
to go.
And you know what,
I'd rather give my time
and opportunity to somebody else
who desperately needs it.
I'm out.
Greiner:
Okay, so, I love meditation.
I do.
But I don't think you need
to actually be raising
more money.
I'm not even sure
that it's so responsible
at this point
to your investors.
While I might be a customer,
I won't be an investor.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Cuban: That's why I called you
a gold digger.
It wasn't a personal issue.
It was more about coming here,
not really wanting a deal,
but looking to get
the commercial.
That sounds
pretty personal.
Branson: I think
"Shark Tank's" for people
who have all kinds
of different businesses
and all different kinds
of backgrounds.
It's funny.
I was talking
to my son earlier today,
and he has learned meditation
recently.
And he just said
how wonderful he feels.
I've not meditated.
I've tried once
and I just fell asleep
when I was trying to ‐‐
trying to meditate.
[ Chuckles ]
I'd love to be converted
into meditation
because those people
who do meditation
seem a lot happier
than those people who don't.
So, I would be reluctant to get
involved at the $600,000.
Oh, shocking!
Oh, what happened?
Shocking!
So ‐‐ So ‐‐
Just 'cause you ‐‐
Just 'cause you
crap on her
with a fancy voice...
No. No.
doesn't mean it's not
the same thing.
No, I'm ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
[Laughing] I'm just gonna ‐‐
I'm about to throw water
at these two guys.
Could we possibly come in
at $300,000 and maybe for 10%?
No, no, no, no, no,
Sir Richard Branson.
I'm asking a question.
It has to be $600,000.
Oh, okay.
I think the water
just has to go.
[ Laughter ]
Let me ‐‐ Let me tell you
what I think.
[ All gasp ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
I'm out of here.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
and things have gotten fiery
between the Sharks
as they debate the motivation
for Yunha coming into the Tank
with her meditation app,
Simple Habit.
Greiner: Let me ‐‐ Let me
tell you what I think.
[ All gasp ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
[ Gasps ]
♪♪
Oh, my God!
I'm out of here.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if the show can't go on,
the show can't go on.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God.
Herjavec: Yunha, I‐I‐I think
it's so disrespectful to say
just because you've done
a great job of raising money
that you don't deserve
to be here.
Everybody who can make it here
deserves to be here.
So, welcome to the Shark Tank.
I just ‐‐
John:
Are you gonna give her money?
Well, hang on.
Richard offered you
$300,000 for 10%.
You need $600,000.
I'll give you $300,000 also
for 10%.
So you've got $600,000,
if Richard
will come in with me ‐‐
At 20%.
There you go.
Branson: First of all,
excuse these very rude people
on this panel,
which, of course,
I've punished one.
We'll ‐‐ We'll sort
the other one out in a minute.
The last thing anybody
should be embarrassed about
is having raised good money
for their company.
And I think the bigger
the war chest you have,
chances are that you'll reach
millions of people
around the world.
And I would love to see
if I can help you reach
those millions of people.
I really appreciate the offer.
Um, but I do have the obligation
to stay fair to some of the
investors that have, earlier on,
invested in me
and gambled on me.
I mean, you have to agree
that there's a value
in having a Shark.
So I think, as Mark said,
we're not ‐‐ I'm not ‐‐
I don't feel compelled
to offer
at the same value
as the other investors did.
With all due respect to them,
make us a counter.
Would you be able to do
$10 million of valuation?
Yeah.
We're going to build
the world's largest platform
for health and wellness.
We are changing
people's lives ‐‐
people that are going
through cancer,
that are going
through divorce...
♪♪
Yunha,
why are you crying?
I just get a lot of letters
from people that
we changed their lives with,
um, and I‐I'm not lying.
We get so many letters
from people
that are going through
difficult times in their lives.
While I understand this
is an investment opportunity ‐‐
But I really think
that we can really
change the world together.
Yeah, I‐I ‐‐ Yunha,
I‐I love your ‐‐
your drive with it.
It's obviously
deeply personal to it.
You know,
your counter's roughly 6%.
I can't get there.
I mean,
I'll go down to 15%.
I'd love
to be involved with it.
I don't want to speak
for Richard.
I'm very happy to do it
on that basis.
Herjavec:
You've seen the show.
There's tremendous value
of being on here.
I actually think
there's a val‐‐
That's why she's here.
I actually think there's a value
add to your investors
that perhaps
you're not factoring in.
You valued the visibility.
You valued
the increased marketability
and the value
to your product.
But you really
didn't value us.
‐Well ‐‐
‐And I get ‐‐ I get
your position that
the three months of accel‐‐
Leave me alone.
He's not ‐‐ He's not ‐‐
Yo! Bro!
You're not involved
in this.
Leave me alone.
Yunha, he's ‐‐
he's out already.
We're happy ‐‐ We're happy
to do 15% if you'd like it.
Yeah.
I am thrilled.
I would love
to be involved with it.
I just can't do 15%.
Yunha, I‐I think you're being
a little short‐sighted.
I'm out.
I don't think
she's being short‐sighted.
She's doing what's right
for her ‐‐ her shareholders
for ‐‐ for her company.
She's got the money.
Congratulations on creating
an incredible company.
Good luck.
But, sadly, I'm out.
I wish you all ‐‐
all the very best.
Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congratulations, Yunha.
‐Good luck, Yunha.
♪♪
I‐I did this because ‐‐
out of passion.
I wanted to change
a lot of people's lives.
But [Sniffles] just to see it
as a financial opportunity
like that
and ‐‐ and say that valuation
is ‐‐ you know, a gold digger
felt a little harsh to me.
Part of what we're able
to accomplish on our show...
Yeah.
...in our nine years
is educating
potential entrepreneurs.
Right.
I do the show because
kids that watch the show learn.
When I called this woman
a gold digger,
it wasn't a disrespect to her
or her company
or what she's been able
to accomplish.
It was the fact
that she didn't care
if she got a deal.
She was here only because ‐‐
Herjavec:
That's not true, Mark.
Oh, without question.
And she ‐‐ We see it all
the time with Silicon Valley.
Let's take ‐‐
Let's take the other point.
Hang on a second.
You're telling her she doesn't
have the right to be here.
No! Robert, no.
You know what it takes
to get a deal on this show.
We've seen people, particularly
from Silicon Valley,
who look at us as a growth hack.
They could care less if they got
our money or our expertise.
They just wanted
the commercial.
I think that's wrong.
We're blowing something up
completely unfairly and ‐‐
She's smart.
This is "Shark Tank," right?
You are here
to come in and get a deal,
and the whole idea
that we have Sharks
is because we're supposed
to add more value
than any of the other
investors out there.
You're ‐‐ You're gonna get
the deal that Mark Cuban likes?
Why can't she get
the deal that she wants?
Branson: Tell you what I find
slightly embarrassing ‐‐
We're talking about
a meditation ‐‐ a meditation ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
...a meditation...
‐We need some meditation.
‐I need a hair dryer.